guys
there's one last trailer
and i'm not sure what it is
breath of the wild too breath of the
wild too breath of the wild to you
brother the world too there it is look
it's moblins
and the goblins have the new horns and
there's a night
oh my god what is this oh it is time
are the
what is that
is that zelda
a sacrifice
that is zelda she was being sacrificed
hey who are you holding hands with over
there girl
oh okay
okay
all right
guys it's happening he's diving from the
air
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh that's so sweet i knew that you were
gonna be able to do so many things with
the reversing
okay still
[Applause]
excuse me
the title the title the legend of zelda
the legend of zelda
tears of the kingdom
tears of the kingdom we have the title
oh my god you guys oh my god
okay it's time to analyze this trailer
and we have an official release date
okay it's a little bit later than we
were thinking
that might even be summer i don't know
but okay may 12 2023 the legend of zelda
tears of the kingdom is coming out and
there was a lot that happened in that
trailer
there was a lot that happened there's a
mysterious new beast or something or a
deity
there you know there was a surprising
lack of gannon that's all i'm going to
say there was a surprising lack of gan
and i'm gonna pause this because i think
it's over okay there was a surprising
lack of gannon in that trailer all right
and i think everybody can agree with me
there however there was also a butt ton
that happened and i think we need to go
back and really analyze the runes that
it showed okay uh because it had a bunch
of zonai stones i believe along the
edges
it had obviously the moblins and the
goblins man if there's another prophecy
happening here this opens up so much
another prophecy opens up so much okay
you guys i love you all but i am going
to get to work analyzing this trailer
okay so thank you all so much for
hanging out with me and watching this i
cannot believe they waited till the end
to release it i'm containing my
excitement i love you all
let's go guys